and it froze
did it really freeze yeah sick awesome
it's fine he's gonna fix that what's up
guys it's Monday obviously this is me
I'm Eric that's John Luke we are gonna
check out destiny to PC beta which is uh
closed beta both stop working that's
fine that's because we've been messing
around stuff it's a closed beta today if
you pre-ordered however it's an open
beta tomorrow so if you want to check it
out
just watch here today if you haven't
pre-ordered if not you can check it out
tomorrow for free hmm the one major
difference obviously other than keyboard
mouse here would be that there's I think
one new crucible map that's what we knew
that's not on console hopefully now I
can go to game pip yeah it should Bungie
now okay old z4 geforce experience
what's up everybody though thank you
guys for tuning in we appreciate it
of course we started we are gonna go
warlock for sir or no no we're not I
lied to you no you're not don't lose a
hunter yeah I'm sorry I thought you put
it I thought warlock in my head because
I remember last time you're capturing
warlock footage but your tech Joyce
hunter is your way of life my way of
life is Titan but you can go hunter
let's do it that's been good here we go
okay so uh let me set resolution in the
beginning but it didn't let me go into
like that OB slider stuff in it we'll
get into that I don't know that's a good
question I think we can skip I think we
can skip I'm gonna make the decision
yeah I'm gonna go it's there for you
guys to watch all over the place it's
nothing new there so but yeah see Bob
Jones gets it huh yeah Bob Jones can you
play beta with controller I'm not sure
we haven't tested it I wouldn't be
shocked if you could it could like I
would think you could rather is what I
would say well I don't know about beta
we haven't tried it but I would assume
that once it comes out you should be
able to
so how long is the beta for I believe
it's three days if I recall correctly I
think 22 the 31st I'll double-check that
for you so we're gonna go through the
first mission here home cause it
it's called homecoming
North yeah it ends the 31st at 10 a.m.
however with console version they did
extend it they did extend the beta iron
meter that so they wanted to keep
testing stuff obviously so and the other
interesting fact if you guys didn't know
this is that it's on the Blizzard app so
I'm battled on it yep essentially Harry
Vickers we actually did bring back cam
and Seb for a limited run at e3 he
triple they were on our co-op stage and
you know every now and then we do still
partner with them and we love them
I miss Cameron stuff personally but you
know I got their own they're part of the
UK office they did Skyrim mods among
other fun things they have their own
kind of let's go let's check out hot
settings here do yours it looks like
your mouse is crazy high sensitivity are
you OC Bob there you go there's
controller if you were to play
controller so that's good yep that just
on the edge I may be all right well you
can always adjust it actually fine keep
mapping all that could stay forward so
this was tough for me when I play PC the
first time because I've also used I was
so used to playing muscle memory wise
controller that like it was really weird
to play keyboard but like once you kind
of get used to it it I think that when
you played you you thought that the key
bindings and suffer great they're fine
fo b/c yep there is a hot fov slider
like what 600 we're gonna go higher than
that
oh you can 105 is the mass a bit weird
let's try a hundred okay see how weird
it looks graphic settings so to follow
the to custom
not max anti-aliasing okay yeah
texture quality highest shadow
depth-of-field
environmental detail okay so it seems
like you're kind of set on high what's
in this uh PC we have a 1070 in there
okay we can pop it up if we want maybe
later but I don't want to yeah let's I
mean like obviously the game is picking
what's best for it right now right so
maybe later we can mess with that yeah
oh it does have adaptive resolution
which is nice nice so that is cool more
games need to have that feature in game
chat all that good stuff gameplay like
reticle reticle color helmet always on
real names full battlenet time I used to
change my reticle color and neck csgo
hood occupancy no subtitles color blind
if we turn on subtitles people can see
it cool okay alright here we go
so I think we've had this discussion and
I'm sure there's gonna be people that
also have to consider this but like I
always asking you like oh yeah what are
you gonna do cuz I I would say you enjoy
PC gaming right so and this game is
finally coming out - to PC are you gonna
play PC when it watches eventually which
is coming out later obviously than
console but are you gonna stick to ps4
no I'm definitely a lot of friends who
are waiting or gonna play ps4 and then
switch to there oh really okay so I'll
definitely play a little bit of it but
as far as which one I'll make my primary
I don't know I mean it's basically more
geared probably towards where your
friends end up right so like if they
decide to go all PC chances are your
quality switch to PC I would assume
right if it turns out it's not big of a
deal that kind of makes me wonder if
like I'll beat it on ps4 but maybe I
won't invest too heavily and a lot of
side stuff or like okay
like not too crazy yeah you know doing
everything but not necessarily for sir
saying am I the only one who can be
easily used both the ps4 and Xbox
controller with no problems I find it
difficult unless I for some reason have
the elite controller where I can then
swap kind of where the thumb stick is
that's me I don't know it is a little
bit weird for me to go from one to the
other but fire-eater saying to activate
super on PC press control delete yeah
how about alt f4 - right I'm pretty sure
alt f4 is something I will say out of
the exotics that the classes get the
Guardians get at the beginning I'm
pretty sure I could definitively say for
me in PvE sure-shot is the best because
it's pretty much kind of like a mini
fate bringer because you get the riot
the fire rounds and then you also get
that like explosive headshot which is
pretty nice so I am jealous with hunters
for that specifically screen okay that's
kind of weird W&S to move up and down
yeah so cool I am kind of sad that my
Titan will have a sweet business but you
know it's fine I get I did see a trailer
where I think the Warlock had sure shot
so maybe if I just play the hunter just
the beginning maybe I can swap the
weapon over we should test that day one
actually I like this mov that's so nice
gonna screw you up a little bit later
like you're gonna miss it when you come
come console so it's less with SS to do
with the amount of distance from the
screen for me when I'm up close on PC I
need that big like fov you know like 80
it just feels like a really
claustrophobic when I'm playing on a
like a couch far away from a TV I don't
really care
it's fine 10 Gill he is using a mouse
there it is boom showed it to you for a
hot second LeTip so open beta Danilo
starts tomorrow so you know I think you
can possibly preload I'm not sure closed
beta was able to reload the other day so
you try that out reload yeah we'll see
son shot that's right Mike Chapelle
shuffle
man destiny gun sounds are still by far
like one of the Bell we acted just it's
got a nice like weighty feel for certain
guns and just always feel like got to
give enough credit for sound effects so
also the fun thing too is like if people
are newer to destiny to you all those
Guardians now have a third new ability
so technically John Luke doesn't have to
reload here he could just do his little
the little roll the shade step
essentially and if you do that question
how do I do that you should look at your
- it's uh kill that guy first though cuz
apparently there's a possum sick
yeah let's maybe look at that real quick
there's my emotes sick good to know
she's good that's weird
up up weird old crash control class
ability is a V okay so it's B air move
air move interact grenades because you
can also I think you can do that the
dodge roll in the air too so if you shot
it a couple times and then maybe it'll
reload but you just reloaded it oh no
I'm going okay
David aged overclocked gt9 at gtx970 you
have to play the PC video you played on
xbox one can't wait to play on this
should be good
I am a little sad there isn't cross play
but I kind of get it
so it's the Makri basically you know a
little roll + reload is how I'm gonna
call it I might refine that that's a
little awkward
oh that it's B yeah yeah the fun thing
is too is I feel like you're gonna be
able to do some nice if your mouse has a
couple more buttons it's gonna be nice
to add those like side bumper buttons as
actually an app that I'm definitely so
like you know melee like is it eat
what's eat these interact okay maybe f
no a super okay here Ark Strider
this is basically like an extended
version or a longer version of arc wave
but it's still cool you can also throw
it right I think I feel like there
there's a throw in my throw the stick
I haven't played too much Hunter even in
the last beta I played mostly a Titan
warlock so is that the hunter exotic
yeah Jake Garcia this is the hunter
exotic you start with every class gets
an exotic off this first mission country
gets a hunter gets a really good hand
cannon the Sun shot the Titan gets the
auto rifle sweet business which looks
like a Gatling gun and then the warlock
gets an SMG that I'm forgetting the name
of it kind of has doesn't work
Oh doesn't bind not yet maybe what was I
it's it's like zalo supercell the hunt
the warlock SMD it's similar but not
exactly the same it's not as good as I
can do that at least and then I can do
willow Cooney do you guys have a clan
and can I join it for d2 we haven't made
it yet but we're actually gonna probably
make it hopefully this week it'll
probably be the gamespot clan if you
just talked about it this much yeah we
talked about this morning funny enough
so when that happens we'll try to send
it out on social media you know you can
follow at GameSpot on Twitter I'm at 8a
at on twitter he's at John Luke psyche
I'm sure we'll make some tweaks when
that happens yep clans are joinable
between so this whole plot yes so this
is the interesting thing right like I
feel like every time I do a story you
just happen to run into some other folks
in this mission or somebody
right and you we're going back and forth
about whether they're real or not right
yeah but those have to be right I think
they're also don't get screwed over like
I did and not be near Zavala when you
drive his stupid shield the bubble and
he's like get near me accordion and they
give you like no time the best was
winnin at one time Aaron found a way to
get him killed and he disappeared off
the screen oh really yeah like a weird
bug J Garcia yes it does have elemental
damage it is a solar the weapon
structures are different now you have
kinetic which is your primary like
number one weapon you have elemental
which is your second weapon but those
still are kind of like your old
primaries in a way so you can have a
hand cannon you can have a pulse rifle
SMG sidearm so those can be in the first
two slots and then now you have a third
tier which is called your power weapons
where you'll have grenade launcher
sniper rocket launcher fusion rifles
those can also have elements is it okay
also yeah you're getting that 60fps on
PC that you won't get on lacan I'll say
I felt this way when we played it a
while ago with that event and it's don't
feel the same yes
at least for the single-player mine is
way easier my mouse keyboard because I'm
just able to accurately like shoot these
guys know there's movements are sort of
designed for a slower controller in mind
so this
probably why there won't be cross play
to cook for like because of competitive
multiplayer in terms of like oh the
advantages that you'll have
PC obviously compared to console so and
if you guys want to have that debate
shor I still think that a keyboard mouse
is generally gonna probably out gun or
outplay a person on console just because
of the ability for you know your how
much faster you can react with them
yeah and it does have a higher
resolution settings right like I mean
obviously we're not gonna do it here but
we can we were able to play 4k at the
event we went to which is also another
Pro for those people that are
potentially playing you know gonna play
on PC if you have 4k monitor so that is
that one of the things that could be a
draw for me I do have a I finally do
have a 4k like PC monitor so that could
be a reason to get PC but it's really
hard for me to invest like the like the
what one month plus of time that I'm
gonna spend on console to then replay it
on PC like I don't know if I'm gonna do
this because at first and cross-play I
would have at least like oh yeah like
sharing this stuff across yeah just like
hey I'm switching over to this console
I'm sure yeah I don't I don't know
internally or whatever but I'm sure they
yeah well I mean I think it's tough too
because like I think I said this on
another stream the other day but my
greatest example of why it's not gonna
work anytime soon is if they can't even
get Diablo 3 to work console to PC I
find I they've never said openly that
they were gonna do that I'm just saying
that they've never done that right so if
they can't do that I find it hard to
believe that they're gonna do it for
like destiny that was a big reason why I
didn't get the console version because I
thought about it was like be really cool
my couch it's actually it's actually
really good
no it seemed good but I really wanted I
didn't want to start over with my
characters yeah that's fair I mean it I
just want to say like that experience is
like it was surprising for me like how
it actually worked out like I thought it
would be really weird because I've
played Diablo all my life I'm a keyboard
mouse and it was like there's no way
this is gonna feel that great to play on
you know console and so you know it
ended up being I ended up really
enjoying it and I thought it was a great
uh you know couch co-op thing that you
know I hope yeah homie 3 not only I'm
not gonna argue that path of X I I think
path of Exile has had more longevity
than Diablo baby it's got a great job
there
finding your games so but still enjoy
Diablo
what are your thoughts on the $200
collection collector's edition ask J
breakfast I mean if you want to buy that
edition and you have the money to spend
in your huge destiny fan I think it's
worth it right but I think for most
people that's by kind of a lot of money
so collectors are editions are
collector's editions for a reason oh
this time people we are getting one to
unbox yeah well why don't we um contact
him about it yeah well Cooney saying lol
I got the 150 Edition for v2 nice you
know I hope you enjoy it's gonna be sick
I think I mean if you got the money for
it cool I think I bought taking king
collectors but that was the only
collectors I bought I bought the limited
in whatever Edition oh wait there wasn't
it taken king collect there was was it
okay maybe I was thinking one other one
yeah no I I bought it for the first
launch and
yeah I think for me the one I would buy
personally if you know All Things
Considered is I'd probably at least get
the game an expansion pass bundle so I
think it saves you like 10 inchh dollars
yeah overall overtime because you get
the you get the DLCs for 15 instead of
20 each that was the big thing with the
limited version mhm
yeah so if you think you're gonna go for
the long haul obviously you know you're
probably don't want to buy that edition
another fun thing is with those guys
like you can treat them like division or
you can shoot their tanks they explode
uh hey he didn't man says I see no
difference between this version console
it's probably hard to tell on a stream
but if you were to see it up close in
person like and compare the two it's
very different yeah I mean we're not
playing at 4k obviously then also
exactly Jay Garcia's saying yeah he did
also buy the taken King collectors for
the strange coin that came with this
nice yeah that was a good one and then I
think the fun thing was last time I
remember when deej came he happened to
have strange goings-on in him and I
remember we got a couple for the some of
the folks that were destiny fans know
okay tell me because I feel like I have
I have two total so maybe I can drop you
a strange coin yeah I harvest I'm really
glad that the PC gamers out there
finally got to play some destiny I think
that that was a big thing for Destin one
that unfortunately there was a
demographic that just you know they
weren't gonna play on console and this
is a brand kind of new thing for them
and for you guys so I like the SMG you
got to talk to the thingy
if a little too unwieldy on control whoo
that that I think it's gonna be pretty
tough Crim some some reef 5x5 wonder if
I can play D - I'm max with a 360 100
and a 10 60 I don't think try it yeah
see what happens here all right maybe
you want to turn off shadow play oh yeah
maybe I could do that yeah there we go
just so we can have as much let's find
out why all of these settings but you
think we're just gonna kick you out now
oh cool okay cuz like sometimes you know
when you change graphics any noticeable
stutter no no no dip an input okay
because chugging a little bit it's not
bad or anything but where notice about
like pcs pretty BP the only thing that
its it may be lacking is it doesn't have
a 1080 chris is a 1070 but in terms of
all the other specs it's an i7 it's got
at least I think 32 gigs of RAM
might you beat your GPU for this guy
yeah like crazy max Phi if you want 4k
and stuff like that this is a new weapon
type 2 for those of you that are not
familiar it's a grenade launcher that's
new to destiny actually don't find like
I don't find it as good or that I
thought as good as I thought it would be
because it's not it's not what you think
it would be right it's not like that
quake Unreal Tournament kind of like
you're lobbying into the ground like
balancing them for damage like this is
more like you have to direct directly
hit them with it and then okay here's a
fun thing let's see if they changed this
are the next part later with the turbine
we heard about we heard some changes to
the turbine thing so we'll be interested
to see if there's any changes here could
compare it to the console version if not
then I'm not shocked by that or anything
I want to see if that's good yeah 1070
is a pretty good card obviously it's
what I have a but you know maybe to run
this at like 4 days max and 4k you're
probably gonna need a little bit more
than that I have a 4k monitor home but I
do have every TV I'm working TV but I'd
have to play before that yeah but I do
have a.m. you see a lap dog 14 yeah I
like that but I have a 1440p monitor
which is pretty good oh that's fine yeah
I like still working for TP like it
looks really nice
that'll probably look pretty good
lieutenant 70 is that pretty good man
it's very good it's true it's true
neurosis hey what's up Dan Oh lap dog go
Roccat soba I just got one let me see
what that looks like okay so it is a oh
okay so it's like a it's essentially
like okay it's like a built-in keyboard
lap dog in a way so it looks a little
like a little bit cleaner ha ha hee -
man that's a good joke he says my xbox
one ex will make the PC version look
obsolete I think that's a good joke what
do you think
[Music]
I mean you still won't be able to play
it it frames that's true locked 0hx
c0 7 says 2k is the sweet spot I like to
Kay a lot honestly I think 4k he'd say
point words have been harder to tell the
differences I think 2k feels noticeably
Chris Berg yeah but I like it I think
it's a good sweet spot they're pretty
cheap to get like a cow splinter 1 and
if you can't bring up a good point he's
saying that 4k might be a little bit too
demanding for 1070 it recommends a 970
for 1080p so yeah yeah max settings
probably yeah Craig the nog I agree with
you he says the best weapon type in
power category is undoubtedly the fusion
rifle it absolutely melts in PvP yes I
agree when I discovered the power of the
fusion rifle in crucible on ps4 I was
like I gotta go with this also because I
think you get more ammo for the fusion
rifle too which is like a nice little
plus so it's like you're gonna get more
shots out of the fusion rifle and as
long as you're charging it and letting
it rip you're gonna get them in one
probably one burst I think I always
forget exactly which one I was using
I'll have to take a look at the PvP
weapons once John Google gets into that
later if he gets lucky and gets it
there's a couple feet there's like two
fusion rifles I think that you can
acquire at least in the console beta
that were
legacies or YS says how come when people
show gameplay they never change like you
mean like down site 80s how like this
yeah maybe maybe like on loose all about
hip fire is all I can't fire to be on it
I like I 80s a lot I mean I'll do that
you know I'm gonna be like I think I 80s
like too much almost cuz like definitely
can hip fire like on their closer you
know what I do it a lot more on
controller but I feel like it's because
I need that extra persuasion on mouse
and keyboard I feel like I can just hit
fire okay that's a good point
Oh see ya
please Steve but hurt while saying
speaking able to the Xbox 1x I snagged
up the order and see them going for like
1,200 now should I be a scum and Scout
my pre-order I'm not gonna tell you any
business practices about like what you
should do with your Xbox one X but I
find it crazy that they're 1,200 now
though that's what I mean at the same
time like I did not change people were
uh you know doing a lot of stuff to
would they sell the snez yeah that's
good to know
all right well you just killed three
turbines this is kind of like that added
platforming that they did you shoot the
turbine right and then you got a like
once that overheats then you got it like
avoid this thing from smashing you jump
up and then drop down to the next one
yeah you could go up top to stay safe -
oh maybe you can't cuz you're on fire
you need to get down there before that
no it's the same
I don't know it's it's just it might be
more annoying it's just more of an
annoyance I feel like those things look
slower though
yeah I'm trying to doubt people but
everyone was like oh that thing was so
hard and stupid and I was like I I'm not
gonna lie I died once only not like
realizing like that could be a thing and
then I was like oh right this totally
makes sense that it's gonna kill me like
why would I not avoid that oh it doesn't
say if people did say it changed okay
wasn't there two roads of speeding
things before yeah or no no isn't that
the strike the strike is a strike might
have to we'll find out we're gonna find
out I remember Falcon night gaming yep
buttery smooth it was smoother earlier
when we're on high though hmm
yeah we weren't on Macs although this is
still pretty smooth this still waist
smoother than console for sure Jack's
design it was much harder last time
because it wasn't clear what you had to
do that Dad yeah I could see that but
now I think people know what to do
Thanks to everyone for telling us that
exchange agree awesome there used to be
two turbines okay so there you go Oh
some someone set it free yeah three now
it's two oh okay yeah okay that makes
sense that's why I was like oh man you
got a lot more time than I'd like when I
did it cuz I thought I went from two to
one but now is three da I'm like like I
struggled with that thing for high
seconds like
you just lost your gun man
turns out we need six of us to kill this
right whatever that happens he's gonna
be the rain probably I'm still holding
out for the tower the raids the tower
yeah baby go through it just like the
rate the movie exactly the way up
exactly you have to find a loss or Judge
Dredd if you guys watch that yeah new
judge good yeah get a frame
I believe you can play the open beta
without the preorder Amano liver so try
that out tomorrow get the blizzard app
and then you know get destiny you should
be able to do that tomorrow yep thanks
everyone in chat also first-time
permanent we show you that three G once
he game says this demo alone has more
story than all of destiny one can't
totally argue yeah I could see where
you're coming from
Caleb gives him carry yeah I'm gonna
call him Gary I'm not gonna call him
call who's gonna call me call come on
alright so so far this looks the same
yep that's you think it's in effect
right that's good some beta effect on
your show I wonder if sometimes certain
effects you turn on don't activate until
you liked exit exam come back in so it's
possible not all the effects we applied
only three 908 says are they all right
or he could be making a statement they
were adding your weapons to the PC beta
or sure we'll find out I know most of
the weapons from console beta so I
should be able to tell you if there's
any ones I mean if he looked in his
inventory right now I think I could tell
if I think the ones that he has right
now are like the old stuff so yeah
showrunner skate lock red Mamba Archon
SunShot black scorpion yeah those are
all from better Oh better devils pro tip
for anyone that hasn't played pc better
Devils is legit for for crucible cool
it's not easy that was real easy
it has explosive rounds it does the
deeps and it's very accurate seems like
the the invite system is pretty
for it he might be trying to talk I
don't know that well tell him too bad
we ain't got no mics for him yep the
main ingredient snap JT one-shot fusion
kill great for crucible as well if once
you get it either I think you might be
able to get it through the strike but
you'll also probably be able to get it
through we are conditional which are
random drops but yes the main ingredient
is my power weapon of choice at least in
the current set of guns that are
available in the beta
unless there's new ones that we don't
know
mono liver we're not sure what the max
level in destiny 2 is yet currently you
know your it looks like you have like
200 power or light level depending on
how you want to call it and then it
looks like level 20 there so we'll have
to see if that's max I don't know are we
gonna start at level 1 on day 1 we'll
have to see
we'll find out in a week or at least on
console I don't know if we got it
presumably it's the same thing yeah us
so the person that asked about dark wood
we haven't played dark wood
unfortunately so I couldn't speak to
that I guess the question here I'm also
curious about is loading times seems
like they're maybe faster I would
side-by-side it's a pretty good it's a
pretty good one it seems like we got a
stir seems faster yeah I didn't even
think about that to be honest that's a
pretty big factor all right oh my thing
that you can do in the future they have
to do it now is that the way the game
works now you can actually do everything
from like I think the current UI without
having to go to orbit so in theory like
if you wanted to you could change like I
think you could go to crucible right now
if you like it wanted to for some reason
oh that's cool
because in crucible I was able to go to
like a strike I think so hopefully I'm
not lying
I guess chat will tell me if I am or not
and I love the shirt size I think I
think for sure what I'm gonna try it day
one is I am gonna go Titan but I think
what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna play
hunter like real quick get it oh but
then I don't know how long it takes to
get to a social space that might not
work then you're gonna try I was trying
to move the gun over yeah I was gonna
try to move the the sure-shot over to my
Titan because I'd rather have the sure
shot than the want the sweet business
platforming real talk I died the first
time because Titan jump got changed I
try to jump like hella far across that
didn't that was not a good idea
I hunter is by far the easiest class to
jump and do platforms on yeah the double
jump gives you so much room for error
and then if you had like bones of a ow
you could triple jump it was like a joke
I had the easiest time doing the the
taking King like platforming with Hunter
compared to the other two with the
spaceship jumps I think there's a text
chat oh that's kind of cool
that might be what that is
I'm not sure oh yeah oh wow look at the
M there's some weirdness happening Oh on
your scope yeah look at do you think
that's it's when I'm right here look
what I'm right here you look up the gun
oh it's pixelated I'm excited do you
think that's because of our settings or
do you think that's just the game I
think that's something weird with the
game because right now it may be not
optimized yet but look weird with the
skybox well PC currently in beta
obviously and they still have an extra
month to polish what I believe that's
really what it is if like the optimizing
everything rising the tools
and their engine to work on PC because
they aren't the same across the board
obviously so do we install the new g4 s
beta drivers yes I installed right
before we started actually looks like a
lighting issue is what a 3G one C games
is talking about yeah we we neurosis as
John Luke mentioned we did update like
right before that's why we're like a few
minutes late we're like oh there's an
update we better host you know install
that uh you can play Titan as your first
main character and get the SunShot how
do I do that Craig the nog is that
something that I eventually get or is
that like the plan I had to do no need
to play as 100 to get the sure Sun shot
once the full game is released does that
mean I get the option because I thought
they were more specific to the class no
worries we'll win a car I mean like if
you're if you're putting in good
information it's not
look at it it says msaa is still under
development as such players may
encounter various issues including
visual artifacts and performance
degradation when using msaa which we are
using we are so that makes some sense
thank you for that information
man this gun is the business this is
that's what I want
the only class specific weapon [ __ ]
will be released later in the game okay
so are you saying I got the option to
chick choose the Sutton shots or is it
something I'm gonna eventually have that
Ferb a case start one eight seven what
do you think of the PC beta
I'll let Joey speak since he is the one
plan what I think of the PC beta yeah
good I mean it's the same thing but as
far as like the feel I really like
playing this game on a mouse a keyboard
I feel like I just have the way better
feeling of aim and you know it's really
good I think like shooter controls in
general but just having that extra
sensitivity see how I do in multiplayer
that was the one thing when I we tried
at the event I got my ass handed to me
at the multiplayer has been used to sort
of everyone having this sort of auto aim
or aim assist and if there's none of
that yeah so it's felt a lot more
hardcore like skill base and in a way
that strong word you're using but I
understand I will say that that's why
he's gonna feel good in crucible so that
like you know like when you have two
people you're aiming at one guy you're
shooting him a lot and then for some
reason his buddy decides to roll up
right behind him sometimes that a missus
gets pulled and like you stop shooting
the target you want to so that won't
have so in some ways I mean what do you
want like on a mouse keyboard you don't
want that but I just think it it creates
a little bit of a higher skill ceiling
and we'll check that out and crucible in
a little bit I genuinely believe that
the people who playing on PC Bowl will
be a little bit more of a hardcore yeah
group than people who play on consoles
because of that ex tough ex guy X we are
on a 1070 a gtx 1070 that's the graphics
card we're currently using hello have
fun thanks yeah saying the pair lack
also thanks for the night tours Lenna
leon car at 23 114 and switched at also
and thank you for that MSA information
as well there is gonna be an open beta
for destiny to wolf gaming it'll start
tomorrow so if you're trying to check
that out check it out tomorrow thanks
amber t we're trying to have fun as well
thank you and also um as mentioned so
sid Agrawal said that the exotics will
be taken from you after you finish the
first mission you lose everything as
Bungie said okay that makes sense and
you can get exotics in the game like
coming around yep
well we'll all be praying Arjun are in
Jesus next week to hope that we get some
cool exotics hoping for to get the
whatever Gjallarhorn is is in this game
I think if you preorder you get the ice
cold fusion rifle though which is like
this weird thing for me I don't know how
I feel about that but they said it will
be available yeah it'll be available but
it's just weird to have like this
advantage off the starting right
but you know it looks like a cool weapon
and then also my theory crafting thing
was like okay cool like so they're
introducing ice or like frost as an
element into the game which means maybe
bad guys have that maybe they don't but
maybe it becomes a fourth subclass
because it's been an elemental based
right like it's right now we know that
there's like void solar an arc so I I'd
be really interested to see like the
kind of like a frozen or like a frost
element I think that'd be pretty cool to
have in the game I don't know what those
supers would look like but you know I am
interested in ever add like freeze your
opponents
we're currently playing at 1080p David
because we wouldn't be higher than that
probably but you can play up to 4k on
this PC beta
yep uh-huh as neurosis mentions don't
forget guys if there's a weird exotic
weapon for sale the first week in the
game you probably want to buy it because
everyone didn't buy it like most people
didn't buy Gjallarhorn because their
pilot went all this things like whatever
you know and then it turns out you know
Gjallarhorn yeah that's a good point
yeah but just by Bob Jones did mention
they did have the iron Gjallarhorn as a
like exotic that you could get as a like
part of the like ordering it early but
you had to earn that so hopefully maybe
you have to earn the ice exotic to them
because you had to do a mission to get
Gjallarhorn back essentially and it just
look at burn right it just looked
different I think it was visually
different I don't think it was like an
actual like difference in weapons so
well it's oh no no no what it was is you
had to do the mission to get back
Gjallarhorn period but then the
pre-order had like a custom stinger yeah
yeah but I'm just saying it was only a
skin variant it wasn't like you were
getting the gun off the bat and I'm not
sure if we'd get that gun right off the
bat if you have to earn it but still
what's up a dog that needs 1500
subscribers I hope you get there why
would I waste my coins on an exotic Roth
rocket watch er rip rest in peace that's
true Bob Jones saying I'd love a ice
know frost element yep XFX guy saying
I'm so glad they have an fov slider in
this do I think that any game that has a
fop slider I almost always like like go
close to max it's like why wouldn't you
write quit champions complain a lot of
that Oh cold art is art interesting okay
okay it looked more like I thought it
was like mr. freeze shooting on a frost
but
all right that's now well I call it cold
heart man my bad thank you for
correcting me a k-star at 187 and
Sebastian as well as Syd I appreciate it
guys
no fourth element yeah I'm just theory
crafting guys I didn't say that that
would happen
and thank you Dark Angel I see that it
I've been told it's Ark thank you for
the all Captain arch I get it
sorry for that I apologize that's my
fault
all right that's my fault all right here
we go
did you do the platforming part yet
where's that coming up okay oh I'll say
it's been playing quake and you know
that's a PC game because it defaults to
a fov of 130 by default what you need
you need yeah yeah yeah like you can
turn it down but I'm like you don't want
to yeah as a PC ass PC game right there
all right Bob posted the official specs
from battlenet I'm gonna drop that also
in YouTube chat thank you for dropping
that twitch chat there Bob they open up
settings here if you guys are curious
about official specs and stuff like that
you can turn off MSA yes cool okay so
that's one of the things that they've
probably mentioned as being continuing
to be optimized yep so it sounds like
you're having some issues with that Oh
nope nevermind it's still there okay but
maybe like you said maybe we haven't
tried to exit and come back inside oh
yeah so beta again guys and again they
still have a month to optimize so yeah
this is a hos a Linares this is the
Shrike the inverted spire strike here is
the platforming parts I actually didn't
die on this surprisingly I died I got
really close man
and I'd like at the last second it turns
out like I was right there at the end I
just couldn't find got it the little
drop down yeah so fun fact I was I was
with you at the destiny like launch
event uh-oh
whoa okay there you go I was gonna say
that should have killed you right away
oh yeah
and I got lucky and got through it the
first time but like my teammates dead
you have that invulnerability
yeah those have been see this is the
part that that's tough is if you die a
bunch and then you're trying to revive
your buddies it's easy to get hit by the
next one so you just gotta be careful
like here I personally don't know how I
feel about this kind of platforming I
mean I guess it does add some intensity
or like some nervousness but I don't
know I don't really much care for having
a dodge a big turbine I guess yeah just
to get to like another point that's my
opinion though but uh curious what other
people think in chat and I you know what
I wouldn't be shocked if like farther
along is like I don't even know if they
do the dead ghost thing but like I bet
you there's something past there
probably when they you know they change
level sometimes for like oh yeah yeah oh
no if you keep going or yeah like those
are gonna be fun to find like for black
spindle and things like that yeah
surreal gremlin what's the max level in
the game and what's the max level in
beta don't know what the max level is in
the final version of the game currently
we're sitting at level 2200 like light
level power than these harpies are
different they do a lot more I think
they're like sniper ones
died though Aaron found a way to cheese
this by the way oh really
uh he was able to not this part but the
next platforming part he was able to
stay on that one for the third tier
somehow really wouldn't be a destiny
game without a little bit of cheese yeah
I think that's always fun to watch CAD
winegar it is not coming out until
October I think that they're probably
just fine-tuning the game so console
first obviously and then PC I think it's
like on late october goku black asking
who else is gonna play pc destiny with
the controller maybe wanna men go for it
huh nintendo pro controller haha you
know what bro make it worse I mean it's
PC it works for PC right so yeah I like
the pro controller yeah I like the pro
controller a lot too for that those I
haven't played on a pro controller I'd
say try it out I mean I'm not
necessarily recommending it for destiny
PC but it will work on a PC
pushpop I don't know how much they're
gonna be doing of that in terms of he
doesn't want Bungie to be adding levels
that are baked into the game but you
need a season pass for the content
already I mean it's gonna be hard DLCs
DLC like you're obviously locked out of
service I did what the first one was
they kind of clearly like created have
ways that you could tell like oh they
could update this to be filled with
something like like a drive shot we
gotta jump on a thing all right that guy
has not played console data
come on meals program you're saying I
think using a controller will get you
owned by PC guys with Lou the mouse
keyboard yeah that's if you're playing
competitive obviously single player
every single player I think it's fully
fine yeah don't come that I wonder if
the added precision could lead to some
fun lighten exploits that could only
like like a precision type of exploit
that's like you can technically do it on
console but it's way harder yeah ten
gold there's a fortunately no cross play
that is a little bit sad but I
understand I understand I mean there's
company reasons there's like there's a
bunch of reasons obviously all right
looks like you're gonna drop down to the
next what's gonna happen no he'll he'll
join you guys I think down there shoot
what's up mister chill gamer senpai has
noticed you do not beer we're here
chat with you on five I don't he says
this game is the same as the first one I
don't necessarily totally disagree with
you I mean if you think about destiny 1
and how many you know expansions DLCs
came out and how many quality of life
things happen like they polished that
game tremendously and now destiny 2
basically gets to get the added benefit
of more story better story hopefully
which is what you know a lot of people
have asked from destiny one and then
they get all the good quality of life
stuff that they've learned from d1 and
then now you're getting you know better
graphics eventually it looks a lot
better I I think we had this kind of
talk to John Luke when we're at the
event that it feels a little faster and
so I think that you can say that all you
want but I mean I don't
doing that before the flash man Tony or
maybe I just never got shot by it but I
think that you know if you didn't play
destiny on PC you're definitely probably
gonna get destiny too if you're ever
interested in it and I think if you're
playing destiny 1 on console and you
continue to like it you're definitely
playing destiny - I think this is yeah I
think really it's more that if you were
shown who try destiny didn't care for it
I don't think this game yeah it's gonna
be the sick it's gonna be the same
mostly the same I didn't know at this
point I'd get interested in this game
I'm interested to see you know how much
involvement there are with those NPC's
on those planets I want to see the inner
planets only see the scope of these
planets you know a lot of that stuff
hasn't really been revealed yet the good
thing that we have so far preview wise
is Kali and Alessandro got to check it
out they we have touring the EDC or the
European dead zone
check that out and they've done some
stuff in the European dead zone they've
added I think I've seen like chests but
you can get like during those things so
like there's like maps new treasure
stuff all right you got amanoot and a
helm the took offense the Manute 42 was
a weapon that was in the last beta I
don't remember if that home was I didn't
do as much PvE I did a lot of PvP I
didn't want to go through the whole
strike yeah
goo'bye want to see how patrols change
and stuff like that as well you go right
into competitive that is a in that those
easy I think you okay so the fun thing
and that people should realize is that
yes competitive is not doesn't mean like
you're playing competitive people it
means you're playing some mode which is
more of that Counter Strike mode so we I
forgot about that until like the last
couple days of a time like oh I should
try this competitive mode I'm kind of
don't want to play competitive people
but then I was oh wow it's the whole
mode I'm an idiot
I hope they change that info because it
really should just be like crucible and
then you pick the mode like that worked
fine I don't know why it has to be like
high intensity versus low intensity just
Steven Anderson I want to say open beta
price starts around 10 a.m. which is
when time it started today I cants a lot
of that might have canceled out so we're
gonna do a quick play which is control
there is one new map for control so
hopefully we get that and you that is
the hope the money that's okay okay so
my tip to you yeah would be that you
should use the your devil's hand cannon
that's my pro tip if you're if you're
pretty decent with hand cannons you hit
control to hide it but then the second
you move the mouse goes back that's kind
of how it was thing too so we also
noticed that he mouse over the shaders
thing so it looks like you're gonna be
able to customize shader wise like your
weapon looks yep you can do with like a
bunch of stuff like yeah it's armored
too right and your ships a hot ship
customization Lucy I'm saying Oh her
Incan asked about your glasses said yeah
she's probably doing work stuff so she
should be you were recommending what
what your Devils are better devil sorry
Devils Yuri Devils is a d1 gun
and then I should use it's up to you yes
so the reason why is like if you go back
to better Devils the reason why I say
you should use that is because the
projectiles the last perk on the far
right has explosive payload so basically
you're getting like doubled a mag you're
getting doubled and load for that perk
stability increases range Stephen
Anderson you should be able to preload
it I don't know if you can preload it
today you might be able to arrange see
how that goes
but better Devils for sure like was the
gun I figured out like everyone well
everyone was using that or like the
pulse rifles was the two were the two
kind of like big ones yeah nightshade I
believe XR 187 mentioned is the pulse
rifle that's really good too and I
actually liked the elemental pulse it
shoots faster with less impact but it
was also very solid so if you're eating
the pulse rifles that was pretty good as
well oh this is the mean rap sick we got
a dick awesome
so here we go the other big change is
that it's 4v4 now all crucibles
yeah I got him nice I was had two 80s
there [ __ ] you to 80s a little bit more
in crucible first of all I think yeah a
little sloppy it's all right now I feel
like maybe the speed sensitivities gonna
do me in here Leon car we did turn off
the msaa but we're not sure if it's one
of those things where you actually have
to like exit out for it to take full
effect right because he did turn off and
we're still noticing some of those hello
you know bowling no - thanks one yeah
okay so first off I realize I didn't
actually enable back okay that might be
why but second I'm going to adjust the
sensitivity down by like a couple points
okay that might be a little bit better
current had a pulse rifle greater than
all that's not true goob
pretty sure hand cannon is equally as
strong if you're if you have solid aim
so that's that's what I'm gonna go with
how does multiplayer play The Killing
Joke 77 asks I think it's great I think
that keyboard/mouse definitely has a
good solid feel to it yeah yeah yeah
yeah I like it I like the double jump
shot that's what I do as a hunter power
weapons are up so the other new thing
that gets announced is like you know
when your pick it up it'll tell you who
has power weapon and like what kind of
weapon they have yeah it has a slow
reload that is the downside to that but
remember you're your hunter passive
ability will allow you to reload on the
fly so oh that boy he's gonna get chased
okay we need to grab another point
though yeah just inhaled asking are you
going to Maine on console pc or both I'm
going ps4 as much as I want to play on
PC it's tough for me to wait about a
month to play it and once I get like
that deep into it I'm not gonna want to
reef arm here
sounds like I'm gonna do both up to a
point and that which point I'll decide
which one I'll stick with and I'll drop
you
so maybe on that frontal actually wait
as far as deciding no like a season pass
for buying cuz I don't want to
necessarily buy it for one and then I'm
still locked in so baby I'll wait
once I have the PC version I know which
version I'm gonna stick with that's when
I'll buy that stuff okay so
Macari asks us both what's your favorite
class so far and why Oh answer while
you're okay you can leave the why
because you like Arthur okay hunter
visually I like to double jump a lot I
like capes capes and hoods yeah that is
the one visual thing that I will say is
not fair that you have that the Titan he
just gets a stupid sash loincloth sash
but the armor looks cool on Titan so at
least I'll have that yeah yeah yeah
there you go BAM see this gun is the
legit for me
Macari I'm gonna go with Titan cuz
Titans been my base and stay one I have
to careful yeah and I like the Titan
because I primarily actually like eating
a lot more than PvP I still enjoy PvP
but I feel like Titan is just such a
solid class for PvE we saw a bubble
which is obviously a you know gonna be
clutch in you know rage strikes things
like that so and now I got Captain
America shield which is awesome
obviously oh he's got the he's got the
main ingredient so this guy knows what's
up fusion rifle he's gonna he's gonna go
ham here in a second probably oh no
someone killed him your your buddy meals
okay
Titan was my favorite and destiny 1:2
says Makara yep that was my favorite too
I will say though after playing the beta
at least in PvP if you had full life you
would have got that guy if I had played
more PvP I would say hunter might be
pretty good just because I really like
the auto reload the Makri reload
essentially the were you just use your
hunter ability doing that
and then load your gun and you can shoot
you know okay we got this however it's
the grenade launcher so you know in love
with yeah watch out Oh
so yes Armour a little bit also the fun
thing about Titan is now with a striker
you get to do multiple smashes and
soldier shoulder charges so it's not
just like one smash which is awesome to
me so that was so unlucky saying yeah I
mean he knew he saw that he I saw you
picked up the power weapon it was like
now I'm gonna deny that from you oh so
close some close kills here I mean you
got two years suppose ever been my forte
but this game that's alright I mean
first game here gotta warm up even if I
was to say I would try to help you since
I don't have the muscle memory for
keyboard Mouser probably just just as
bad all right you can get power weapon
yet as Hayden Ross mentioned Titan also
has a personal shield so you can pick
from two variants that's the new third
ability for Titan you can either do the
smaller one which is shorter and that oh
god oh are excited I knew that was gonna
happen sorry you have super to you I
didn't want to use that soon yeah and
then you have a taller one that will
block out more it's actually pretty good
for control it's pretty annoying um to
deal with and actually as enemies try to
walk through it they get like dot damnit
like not dot damage but they get damaged
as they walk through it so they don't
you definitely don't want to walk
through a titan shield if you ever see
one just gave me all the power weapons
got him I feel like I took way too many
bullets well the first two looked like
they shot over his shoulder at Splash
Damage yeah it's definitely not like
your traditional shooting into the
ground
get there Anna get him come on what's
with the ring he's pretty far then he's
pretty far I don't know how the range on
that thing is I'm doing sloppier packs
are just wants to nightstalker for PvE
yeah I hope so we don't know what that
third class is yet but I mean it would
make some sense if it was something
related to that because my stalker was
the PvE hunter class for sure later King
K later thanks for stopping by
that's about sprint it's on [ __ ] yeah
but I mean shift is a pretty common
sprint button ooh so close you say I
feel like I ain't gonna hit fire yeah
that's not good run every way did they
kill him to kill them nice arc Hunter
worse never you got that's not true Bob
I don't think the earth hunter is the
worst I can see why you think kill him
you see why gunslinger you might like
more in PvP but I thought Orchestrator
was fine coming up here yeah so this is
a that's the other thing right that's
slightly different as you have
resilience mobility and recovery now
instead of like int discipline and
strength so you could increase your
resilience so that you don't die as fast
obviously if you have those as yeah so I
would say for now like it's probably
better to beef up your resilience just
so you have a little bit of an edge all
right oh yeah that's the other thing you
can do as a do another one which I
mentioned Niels popped off
please flying with me males is uh when
you're arc shredder you can also dodge
you can use the Dodge to go like Ford
and things like that so that's good
that's another good tip thanks turtle
turtle Titus I think you can answer this
already sorry let's try run the stream I
could switch over to Golden Gun okay
I'll just sorry if this has been asked
already but how is the piece
running right now I think it's running
great I feel like couldn't ask for more
60 frames and Blair's straight job you
want gambler wait recharges the melee
yeah you want I will say the arc charter
the interesting combinations you can do
with the melee one though is pretty cool
because it like yeah you can refresh it
sooner and there's like there's
different combos that you can kind of
put together our Fox Junior is a beta
doesn't start off as the full version if
I'm understanding your question crap to
cool videos open betas tomorrow
footlong game and this is out on PC
today if you pre-ordered it's a closed
beta but open tomorrow we've got this
new map again
XR says the six shot in gunslinger
really needs to change
yeah I see I see why they added it as a
good people kind of thing but maybe it's
not as good in PvP or maybe it is too
good it depends because like the timer's
a lot shorter now though for the Golden
Gun so like if they're not all clumped
up you're probably not gonna get more
than two yeah but um I could see it
being really fun in PvE just like
shooting off six golden gunshots very
quick like hey bang bang bang throwing
ass warmer
okay got one storm grenade on him and he
ran it's a smart play his buddy he's
using nightshade up the pulse rifle uh
Hosea I feel like for me it felt a look
it feels a little faster than b1
Hasaan a Guidi GUI d sorry if i
butchered your last name yeah he's just
two weeks i'm so hype it's actually one
week it's out next week cancel so six
weeks leon car no boy hunter in beta
just arks rider and that's lame
geez blank in that i was like thinking
of all the like other solar classes for
some reason uh streamlining security
asking is the frame way it locked at
sixty or never be unlocked it is
unlocked i believe this see you would
think that would kill him but it didn't
so you got it like that I hate I don't
like behind you okay like I had poor aim
should have killed me uh it's also hard
to tell us on on a stream to see this
like the true sixty probably right
streams I feel like never necessarily do
justice to how I don't love that I don't
know if that shoe supersonic station is
x1x really sixty no right or both locked
at third he said losses are logs at 4:30
yeah same with Xbox one and ps4 Pro and
then there's a huge controversy of like
is it because of the like Sony exclusive
thing they recently made a they said it
was just because of like they'd rather
cuz I could they couldn't they couldn't
I was a game they wanted to make
something they're like well that game
does exist it's called the PC and he's
not a little condescending around in a
way that I was kind of like come on dude
I think the smarter thing would have
been I excuse is that okay it can only
do 30 on regular consoles it could do 60
on ps4 Pro and Xbox one X but if we were
to do that it would make it unfair in
crucible so to you know keep that even
for players we're just gonna long after
like that that is
way to like explain that I think spooky
we're answering as many questions as we
can if you have a question feel free to
shoot it on over and I'll try to answer
it or send it along to John Luke either
way I think Leone car says extreme looks
great on 1080 60 p which is source yep
thank you thank you it's it's 34 consul
guys though just so you know and - Rick
- I think our Fox juniors point you do
get to play the first story mission so
in that regard I guess like the intro is
kind of there for you but after that it
we don't know what's gonna like how it
goes after that right so he's also using
nightshade I keep forgetting that I have
that DS button I never use it and that's
really bad you should you should do that
yeah twitch reflex they grenade
launchers are one-hit kill if you can
actually like direct hit with them but I
think like natural instinct for people
that have played some of those older
games
oh I missed all those like quake and
whatnot just I had the instinct to shoot
them into the ground but yeah I would
just say as mentioned earlier by a lot
of people just use a fusion rifle for
power weapons once you get it because
like main ingredients a one-shot kill
it's like easier to like aim that Oh or
you can snipe or you can with a
copperhead is a social hub from the
first game back no technically the tower
is dunzo but there is a so if there is a
social hub yeah but the tower itself
from g1 is is is dunzo and try this
rocket again alright just make sure
you're you're like aiming for them like
or dump all of them and get a dump it
that's my only solution is to die that's
fine he died though he's dead so it's
fine I don't think it's efficient this
is PC er Fox juniors console beta was
like a couple weeks ago
it'll be out released next week on
console and this guy is crazy charging
with a pulse rifle
come on I believe in you okay that's
another guy a hairy white guy open beta
is tomorrow that's correct yeah I think
you just got a ATS a little bit more
even though might not be happy for you
you know what the one thing I want them
to add in this version is though I
really want them to do what the division
did which is like allow you to have a
different language cuz by God do I want
to play in Japanese now you know how
hype have you heard
yes destiny yes do you know how hype
Shaq's gets he gets so hype in Japanese
it's it like it's so good I'm an
Japanese voice actors some awful
language like the way they express hype
he sounds so much cooler than English
yeah and I mean just uh I think I was
watching the dota at the ti right the
International yeah and they were just
showcasing you know international
casters you know like Korean casters in
particular and just like how excited and
hyped they get like even though nothing
is happening
yeah it just sounds like they're so like
like oh you know like and he's just like
walking the emotion they express
nice well played there I'll drop the PC
specs if you're asking for our PC specs
I don't have all of those on me but it's
an i7 I think I 777 100k with a 1070 we
we have like 32 gigs of RAM that's like
kind of like though most important parts
I guess SSD obviously nice here we go
heating up here heating up this guy's
gonna die - nope ok now like that though
you can try pre-loading I'm not sure if
it's out there yet yeah Spanish soccer
announcers also get very high mmm but
yeah I would really like a Japanese like
voice pack if I could change it I don't
I don't know if that's in the game cuz
like the only way you could get that
right now is if you go like by a
Japanese version of destiny or play the
definitely interesting you ever see that
oh the Japanese kill him taken King add
oh yeah that was so cool in the laundry
along the laundry man yeah that's really
good do you think there is like a big
community I mean you got someone there
playing that's Japanese right I'm pretty
sure that Jeff um I saw its kanji that's
kanji so I don't know but I think
there's a pretty decent demographic I
would assume but I know that of one of
my old raid friends had a had a friend
in Japan playing he was there overseas
like I think teaching or something and
he would play from Japan at school so we
were able to get him into some raids
because we needed an extra person yeah
it's easy to hear the overacting I don't
mind it I like the overact I want the
hype you know they don't see the preload
yet for battlenet that's Leon car so
maybe tomorrow guys maybe have to wait
till tomorrow what's free tomorrow so
you can't throw your weapon at the enemy
allies l-dub oh good we do one more of
this and then we can try there yeah and
then counter-strike mode whatever it's
to be pretty
I'll be good we're pretty good after
that yeah
I push room I don't know how large the
final release will be unlike I don't
know in terms of hard drive space and I
don't know in terms of like content
either so we'll see that's pretty good
that's a pretty good rig a hairy white
guy he says he has a 70 mr. 700k with a
1080 and 16 gigs of ram dang 1440p 60fps
here I come
yeah sounds about right uh oh so hot
let's not get into too much of Game of
Thrones even though that's not even a
big deal there as the season finale was
yesterday I'll just say yeah did you
enjoy it
pretty solid one I watched it so yeah
solid yeah push broom ass and came with
a camera view box up oh oh oh I mean I
don't that should be a solid spot to be
honest I mean I could just get rid of it
here real quick if you wanted to watch
getting point you can do sky read of it
for now that's fine I'm sure
oh you got stuck kill him oh you live
somehow that's weird it sounded like
it's stuck to you so that's the little
shield and you see bagging no keep the
face cam or I'll move it
geez for the stream alright for the
stream I'll move it shortly guys I'll
fix the
boom we're back bottom right yeah come
on yeah kill that guy to retire with him
yeah I feel you Matt downs he says I
really want to play PC but there's no
way I'm starting over a month of playing
console that's the tough one right I
think that you almost just have to wait
in a sense if you're gonna really commit
to PC I feel like unless you're okay
with he's a shotgun yep it's gonna be
tough so okay have you guys gone to the
social space game show it I don't
believe it's that accessible right now
the farm was accessible at some point
like for one day for stress testing I'm
not sure if they're doing that for this
too don't walk through that or you'll
get hurt now OCS f OC sake a football
asking how does that nice lang both
sides everyone's great twitch reflex
says they do have a partnership with
Nvidia so if you buy a graphics card
you're gonna get the game for free I was
like please not like this not like this
supersonic station are you guys getting
an Xbox 1x I'm personally not did you
preorder one nope okay I mean we'll get
some in the office yeah we found a try
but I just didn't really I mean i
currently just don't have like a game
that i would want to plan it so like if
that's not there's no motivating factor
for me to then get an xbox maybe
Assassin's Creed maybe yeah thanks the
only one I can really see it's very cool
this year
so this is a person's opinion double
gaming at GameSpot you can only play
destiny to people with your within your
own region because of the limitations of
battlenet steam would have been so much
better I mean I can't necessarily just
mean I was playing with that Japanese
guy so what do you mean you own the
region so the way battle.net works is
that there's three regions that you can
pick from
you can pick Americas Europe and one is
it Asia for the third one I think so
then if you can only then play in those
set regions and you're locked to it so
like you can't move your character to
Europe you'd have to start another
Europe character but I will say I think
if you own it you at least don't have to
buy multiple copies it's just that you
don't get your character in another
region like he doesn't start over its
region yeah you'd have to start over
though you won't have your character
though that sucks
yeah so that is the problem now
obviously you know activision owns both
companies so it was probably
structurally easier for them to put it
on to battlenet and maybe it's just a
business decision too hard to say nice
Oh our charters gonna clean it up oh
he's got the the Sentinel it's gone
Captain America we should pick oh no you
have max if you guys are gaming media
why would you not have all the consoles
to be fair I mean in internally in the
apocalypse oh yes we won't have we do
all of them I thought you're asking us
personally if we were buying an Xbox one
X um yeah internally we will have some
we're gonna you know play games on here
in the office but as far as me
personally buying one it's not like I
get it for free we got here or anything
like that
Oh Don blaze rolling up Oh
lock and load day one man it's gonna be
tough and adjusting to PC is not
necessarily easy even if I was to try to
play I'm sure it would be pretty tough
for me to get used to the muscle memory
of switching go I'm asking for it so
please bear in mind that that's the
thing nice there you go how's it good
switch seemed teeters just never stop
and never get caught that's a good point
Parker Wilson
I feel like Blizzard does a pretty good
job in terms of like keeping hackers
away or getting rid of them and and they
have the infrastructure for that they do
they're much smaller and and they can
focus on it right they know that that
right like this is a game that they have
to care about and worry about they only
have with you so I'm sure Bungie will
have a dedicated PC team that probably
works yeah
I mean dellwo gaming just again talking
about the the region than one I he says
he's in the UK and has many friends all
over the world in Australia USA and it
just sucks to not be able to play with
them without actually having to realize
but I mean that's kind of
I want to say that's kind of like how it
is on console too though I don't know
yeah I think so
because like I said if I wanted to play
the Japanese version right I'd have to
be on Japanese PSN and then by the
Japanese so play against Japanese
players but yeah but they would have to
be on think the US alright let's try
some hot call of dare counter [ __ ] I
think he called you I've been playing
call of duty all weekend
play fair amount of that yesterday yeah
it was cool Vasko Val hi how can you how
do you compare this with the PS or
compare this with the PS were pro
version the pro version
well pro is thirty pros thirty as far as
visually goes I'm not really sure I feel
it could be pretty my new differences
outside of yeah
so in trial to see like a comparison
yeah we'll have to wait for that hot
digital family and I guess obviously the
major difference is keyboard mouse
versus con you might actually I wouldn't
be surprised if in a day or two they'll
have one comparing this version to like
the console beta mmm-hmm Oh
lock and load do you guys think that
destiny to will as it comes out be a
true sequel or just a destiny one with a
few tweaks I think it'll be a true
sequel I think so too
hope so I hope so too
yeah we got caught up in that like I
don't want to call it destiny 1.5
because that's definitely not fair
mm-hmm but part of me understands why
people want to call it that right but
again this is a beta we've only seen
three things three of which I want to
say outside of the story we've seen
crucible right and we've seen strikes
like they can only tweak that so much so
I'm excited to see the planets I'm
excited to see those NPCs on the planets
I'm excited to see how they change like
the patrols and whatnot with like that
regard and just all those like other
layers that they're adding so in that
regard I think it'll be a sequel so hey
look it fixed that cool oh you got a
queue up I did it was it wouldn't let me
cue up and check my settings of the same
okay uh Austin home and asking you guys
think they'll add more planets in DLC
that's hard to say it did I don't think
they've ever done that
yeah the dread-nots that was the most
yeah I guess that's true if you want to
classify that it's a I guess you could
classify that as a planet I guess it's
actually the same way it the same way
yeah okay so it's possible I guess if
they want to go with that type of a
strategy I think one of them's more
trials of Osiris type based right
because you have that icon and the other
ones more Rasputin uh kind of base the
DLCs right at least in terms were just
like seeing the icon yeah man not
finding anyone in this no roasters
brings up a good point too most people
don't remember sequel games like halo 2
halo 2 ODST etc they're almost all the
same game with some difference weeks
it's true that's true
I think maybe yeah I think maybe
expecting to be dramatically different
is Wow nobody's playing this huh a
little unrealistic you early for this
mode you know what I bet people are
scared that it's the same that thing
where you think it's like you're playing
competitive people maybe that's what I'm
gonna go with you wanna yeah do one more
quick play and then we wrap it up yeah
what's up the shadow hazard the CEMP
eyes hear me and y'all look up notice
you there you go
ax star says I don't get why Bungie
won't allow us to change our character
from d1 I mean you could technically
make a new character alright I mean if
you want to keep your old character then
you keep your old character and you move
it over if not just make a new character
career I want to see if the character
creator is more in depth
this time around like or if it's kind of
like that similar like here's 12 tile
sets right tile sets if the tile set
like the faces look really nice but
there are very limited options a lot of
repeats you see like be my friend
accidentally made the exact same looking
face oh really I like pure accident nice
I'm on fire why does destiny to sell
only on B net I thought they only sell
their own games well Activision owns
both companies and they're using the
like I'm guessing they've got to be
using like blizzards like server
structure or something like that it's
for it to be running on battlenet so it
makes sense that it's being sold on
battle.net
when you when you go on there it
actually says it'll say Blizzard games
now and then the bottom it says
Activision and then it has destiny there
it's kind of implies like do you think
they're gonna start doing them we're
often is kind of one wondering if
they're gonna maybe make that because
the thing is Activision doesn't actually
sell that many games in a year they only
sell like a couple mm-hmm so it's not
like it would necessarily get overcrowd
in but I if they eventually I don't know
like do you think like Call of Duty
would ever do that they'll find out soon
right that's November 3rd oh they would
have announced that by now ok like the
next one the next one I don't know we
got a new like you play situation but
the one thing about that is battlenet
games games on battlenet are very much
like service based games games with a
very long tail yeah you know so destiny
kind of makes sense it's a service based
game
there's patch like constant action is an
update
just anyone ran for like three years
right um call duty is not it has DLC but
it's not a service based game in the
sense that like they put out a new one
every year like it becomes outdated so I
don't think Karla dude in its current
format would necessarily be a good fit
for battlenet do you keep the leaf from
the beta I know you don't The Killing
Joke unfortunately you do not
yeah QuickPlay says I can load well my
guess is that you know betas new today a
lot of people are probably going through
story and strike right because PvP I
want to say it's more niche but there's
probably less people you know doing the
PvP thing compared to PvE so do you
think this will make it as an eSport now
I don't know streamline I mean I think
they're gonna continue to do some of
those like little smaller side
tournaments where they kind of bring you
know some of the prominent streamers and
PvP ears out and they'll have events I
don't know if they're ever gonna go like
full-on though I mean maybe the hope was
that with the kind of four-on-four
maybe that was a way to kind of push
that a little bit I don't think so I'm
gonna give you that really businessí
line which I don't necessarily want to
give you but I mean games like these
like competitive shooters should become
an eSports kind of more through the
community first and then like I kind of
just gave the cliffy B thing even though
like he's like you know no that's what
it should start that way right like
that's blizzards philosophy now I don't
know how much impact that has on destiny
but blizzards philosophy generally is
they want to make a good solid game that
is you know easy to pick up and play and
enjoyable but hard to master and through
that you're hoping then that what that
rag doll that you can it becomes an
eSport that way right but you don't want
to necessarily just build your game as
an eSport first I think that's tougher
so that's my answer - yeah I don't ya
know I feel the exact same way anytime I
see a company that tries to push
something as an eSport before it's like
even close to being out I I think it's
like you guys are trying to get ahead of
yourselves and I don't I feel like
people see through that like mm-hmm
people tend to gravitate toward
something
own accord rather than because we're
trying to tell them it's like any sport
why do you guys love Sonny so much as
supersonic station I don't love Sony
like that much more than Microsoft it's
just that in terms of the games I enjoy
playing they happen to be on a Sony
platform or if they're on both platforms
I already own a Playstation like I just
personally haven't had you know what
game I wanted to buy an xbox one floor
before the Xbox one next time outs
scalebound yeah what happened to
scalebound true that was like the most
exciting game I was ready I was like yep
I'm finally gonna get my xbox one and
it's gonna be for scalebound nice shot
there and then they cancelled it and I
was just said I was just said yeah no I
agree you know they they got the they
got the action games like near they got
the RPGs like persona and Yakuza like
Playstations just got the games I want
to play it really has nothing to do
personal preference
yeah I have zero allegiance to like a
brand or anything like that like I you
know last generation I primarily played
Xbox 360 I had a ps3 and I played some
games on it but I most of the time it
was 360 and then with this ps4 like I
just I go with whoever offers the the
best experience for me personally yeah
you know next generation if that happens
who knows how that's gonna work if Xbox
has it better than PlayStation I'll go
to Xbox life line one will try to see if
we can access that chat functionality
after the game or like yeah I'm really
really curious about that how that works
anyone knows how I activate that I
really want to know I'm still scale down
from never again to saying that's not a
never again it was just more that was a
compelling reason for me and it's gone
now
oh um 10 the HM 50p is there anything
you're excited to play in destiny -
mines are the lost sectors it sounds
like a mini dungeon in an MMO that
sounds very interesting to me I have
always loved the raid yes except for
crota maybe but I've always left the
raid so I'm looking forward to the raids
I'm just looking forward to like I said
more personally more destiny obviously
but they're there to spin and take on
some time me something I stopped them
from getting the power amulet ooh mystic
law any thoughts on Rockstar promotion I
think Rockstar knows what they're doing
hmmm I think they realize that they
don't they're not they can do whatever
they want man oh yeah then when they
want to talk to you and send you out a
trailer they're gonna do it and they're
gonna show up when they want to and I
think that's great and fine like when
they wanted and now it's some more Red
Dead to stuff I'm sure it's gonna be
crazy
Parker Wilson scaled down was crybaby
teen who played with dragons I don't
disappear I thought it was more like a
Dante DMC don't a Dante Dante DMC meets
some dragons and then you can warp into
like a dragon half dragon half man so I
don't know I thought it was cool
that's just me though AK star wants you
to 80s more
on it nailed it nailed it
totally 80s second for chat later he
says press T does that work oh yeah hey
there was worth his meals that's me
thank you for that AR od0 77 thank you
for that
so that was chat real quick and that was
Jack there was my brief chat interaction
that's funny
kind of on a weird spot I guess like
there's nothing I'm hosel in ours I
don't know what type of sliders are
gonna have for character creator I'm
gonna guess it's not gonna be too crazy
I hope it's got something but we'll see
my guess is not much I don't know the
faces look like because we can't take
the helmets off in the beta you can't no
no you can there's the toggle but if you
do it nothing happens okay got it
Arthur Rios is it fov feel different for
ps4 to PC
sov yeah it defaulted to what like 85 at
the beginning which is probably what the
console was and you go to 105
ooh nice I kind of heard the shots but
I'm looking at check I think he means a
rock chart drink that is giving coats
for destiny - Oh what do I think about
that Oh fine
you know what the weirder one is pop
cards yeah yeah okay I say that that's
kind of weird only okay actually it's
not that weird when you think about what
the which company we're dealing with
here we're dealing with Activision right
double but the thing is you get XP bonus
you know that right forget where's the
pop-tarts at dance after my papa
so I am NOT gonna lie I did the Doritos
thing for Call of Duty I didn't buy that
many bags but I bought some bags but the
good thing about that was like the codes
worked more than once so you could give
it to a friend but in the yeah it's on
the back of the bag take a picture
people who like hey who needs a code I
got 10 now themselves okay so rocks are
energy drinks are going to have uh tree
X key codes on the can okay people are
gonna go take pictures of that then
there's me whether in this game now he's
not neither's McGregor McGregor wasn't
call duty though was he yeah using that
one uh was it black ops 3 no sorry not
black ops 3 uh what's the one where you
start off in the ice level and then you
get punched out
do you know shoot cat will chat will
help me out in a second okay but still
kind of getting used to these controls
Oreo pop-tarts is that though yeah what
flavors are they offering with it I
don't know I don't know can't wait to
see all the open pop-tart boxes at my
local supermarket the pop-tart foxes
will have little ghosts on them I guess
he captured Zone C you have don't forget
you got super later yep clear something
out hopefully oh but you got golden vine
huh yeah
just like a random shot yeah that's the
tough part like yeah like I don't know
there might be a toggle we'd have to
look I kind of wish you just could pick
like three slow or six fast there might
be though again then play that much
Hunter yeah the beat oh that's the run
oh we killed them nice rock man can't
wait til tomorrow so I can play it yeah
it's gonna be open beta tomorrow
it was infinite warfare thank you
unmatched poncho and a K star 187 he was
in he was in normal he punched you out
in the beginning he was part of like
that bad team of things okay alright how
do we how do we fare that time not bad
not bad did okay did okay 1.6 KD that's
good it's good not terrible not better
yeah it's pretty good
uh so that was our destiny to closed
beta PC livestream thank you all for
tuning thank you for driving there
yeah don't leak so yeah if you guys want
to play it'll be available open beta
tomorrow it'll run until the 31st and
the game comes out on console ps4 and
Xbox one next week on Wednesday this
which is a weird day I know that got
moved up but it's not the most games
coming out on Tuesday whatever and the
social air is not in the PC beta
unfortunately for those asking but yeah
thank you guys for tuning in we'll be
live again tomorrow we're gonna actually
have Mario rabbits tomorrow which is an
interesting fun game on the switch yeah
I want to pick that up so come back at
11 tomorrow
we got lobby as well on Wednesday and
then we'll be still streaming every day
at 11:00 just so you guys know but until
next time thank eyes so much for tuning
in and see you guys later
by
you